who would win in a fight the megalodon  or the Mosasaur the Megalodon is bigger  and stronger in almost every aspect  compared to the Mosasaur but luckily for  him the Mosasaur does have increased  maneuverability the battle would start  out with the Megalodon being the initial  aggressor but due to it having a lot of  battles in the past the Mosasaur would  know how to fight back as the Megalodon  attacks the Mosasaur it would be able to  use its defensive traits and would hide  from the giant shark the Mosasaur would  then sneak up and try to Chomp down on  the Meg's fin but due to the shark being  so massive it wouldn't make much of a  dent the Mosasaur would try to retreat  but the Megalodon would quickly catch up  to it and Chomp down on the sea creature  killing it for good so the Megalodon  would be the ultimate Victor in this  battle okay you asked for it